[Music]
Dumb Ways to Die Joe Jonas lovingly
trolls his brother Kevin Jonas for
nearly wiping out on stage here we go
guys it all started on Wednesday when
Kevin nearly took a tumble during the
Jonas Brothers residency at the Marquee
Theater in New York City that's Kevin
spinning in circles getting lost in the
music before his guitar hits the
microphone stand causing him to trip and
almost fall but fear not because the
audience quickly came to Kevin's Aid
chanting his name and support before Joe
playfully asked Kevin to apologize to
the microphone stand
After experiencing that awkward moment
together on stage Joe took the jokes
even further reacting to it on Tick Tock
set to the viral sound dumb ways to die
[Music]
he ends the video by gushing I love you
Kevin Jonas now that's some brotherly
love you ought to back your brothers up
if things go down the Joe Bros are
currently performing a five night sold
out Broadway residency performing one of
their Five albums each night from start
to finish it's a show kind of unlike
anything we've we've done before we're
trying to include the fans who have been
with us from day one but they're also
churning out new music like their latest
single wings and the accompanying music
video which features Die Hard fan Haley
Lou Richardson
foreign
it was actually the coolest thing I've
ever done I literally moved to LA when I
was 16 to be an actor and I remember
telling my mom one night when we were
like living in this old woman's house
and we were like sharing a bed together
and I was like mom do you think I'll
ever be famous enough to meet the Jonas
Brothers
we're genuinely a dream come true as for
the guys they're in their best season of
life yet when they're not busy working
they're loving dad life Kevin has two
kiddos with his wife Danielle whom he
married in 2009 meanwhile Joe and his
Leading Lady Sophie Turner tied the knot
in 2019 and welcomed their second baby
in 2022. it's amazing you know genuinely
being a dad rules as for Nick he and
Priyanka Chopra became parents to a baby
girl multi in 2022. it is certainly
life-changing she's uh she's amazing
um brings me a lot of joy
multi was right by his side when the
band was honored with a star on the
Hollywood Walk of Fame to my beautiful
wife I love being a parent with you so
multi-marie hi babe
I can't wait to come back here with you
in 15 years and embarrass you in front
of your friends
[Applause]
bring your girls here
proud does that make you feel as fathers
uh it's a it's a crazy thought
um I think I even said something about
hoping to come and embarrass her here
one day um like it's I was I'm really in
that bed yeah that's just a special
thing and you know I think as as parents
it's everything has a new meaning and
has even more meaning and moments like
this especially
[Music]
thank you